오늘 준비한 고기부터 보시죠
코스트코에서 산 미국산 냉장 삼겹살 원육 4.7kg입니다
코스트코 가보면 이렇게 7.2kg짜리도 있어요
원육마다 크기가 천차만별인 건데요
저는 5kg가 안되는 가장 작은 덩어리를 샀습니다
그리고 이 삼겹살을 조리할 냄비입니다
28cm 11인치 크기고요
오늘 요리는 이 냄비의 지름이 고기의 크기로 이어질 겁니다
저는 있어 보이려고 큰 돈 주고 무쇠 하나 장만했는데요
당연히 여러분은 일반 냄비 쓰셔도 상관없습니다
보통 캠핑 MT 가면 숯불 피워서 철망 놓고 고기를 굽죠
근데 아시다시피 가스불에 팬으로 굽는 게 훨씬 더 쉽잖아요
그런데도 굳이 힘들게 숯에 불을 붙이는 이유는
바로 숯향, 연기, 훈연 때문이죠
한편 우리나라는 돼지를 수육으로도 많이 먹습니다
돼지 육향은 없애는 게 왕도인 식문화이기도 하고요
덩어리 고기를 숭덩숭덩 썰어먹는 맛이 있으니까요
오늘은 이 숯불구이와 수육의 장점만 모은
냄비 뚜껑 훈제 수육을 만들 겁니다
수백만 뷰가 나왔을 만큼 바이럴된 아이디어 레시피인데
한국인이 사랑하는 돼지고기의 요소를 두루 갖춰서
꼭 한번 도전해보고 싶었습니다
다시 고기로 돌아옵니다
구이는 지방을 녹일 수 있는데 수육은 그럴 수 없잖아요
그래서 저는 수육할 때 가급적 이렇게 빅의 얇은 고기를 찾습니다
고기가 사각형이라 냄비 뚜껑에 딱 맞진 않아요
둥글게 만들기 위해 내 귀퉁이를 잘라냈고요
뚜껑 위에 올려서 크기를 확인하고 나면 고기 손질은 끝입니다
이제 요리용 실을 묶을 건데요
냄비 뚜껑 손잡이에 엮어서 뒤집는 방식이더라고요
실 4가닥을 손잡이에 한번 묶은 뒤 양쪽으로 늘려서
피자 마냥 8분할 해놨는데요
처음부터 모양을 잡을 필요는 없었네요
뒤집을 때 주의할 점은 실길이 짝을 맞춰놓아야 합니다
양쪽에서 팽팽하게 당겨져야만 고정이 돼요
8가닥 짝 맞춘다고 한참 시간을 허비했습니다
이제 고기를 묶으려면
뒤집어 보면 예상보다 고기가 처지더라고요
그래서 가능한 한 팽팽하게 세게 실을 묶길 추천해드립니다
이렇게 중앙에 모인 8가닥을 한 대 모아서 묶고 깔끔하게 잘라내고 나면
수많은 마법사를 설레게 했던 냄비 뚜껑의 초 업그레이드 버전
고기냄뚜가 완성됐습니다
아 맞다
또 시즈닝을 안 했어
오늘은 소금 후추 시즈닝이 아니라
수육의 시그니처 된장을 준비했습니다
장려라는 태양 아래서 애써 묶은 실을 끊으며
이성의 끈도 끊어질 뻔했지만
다행히 한번 해봤다고 요령이 생겨서
순식간에 8가닥 재설치를 끝냈고요
고기가 꽤 크기 때문에 된장을 5숟가락 정도 떠서
갈비뼈가 빠져나간 자리까지 꼼꼼히 펴바릅니다
바르면서 다시 차분히 생각해보니까
비계 부분이 냄비 바닥을 향하는 게 좋을 것 같아서
위아래는 뒤집었어요
비계 부분 역시 쌈장으로 도포했고요
다시 한번 팽팽하게 단단하게 실을 묶으면
K시즈닝까지 마친 진짜 고기냄뚜 완성입니다
이제 물을 끓일 건데요
오늘의 광고주님
아이오닉5
아이오닉5의 멀티탭과 커피포트를 연결해서 물을 끓일 거예요
여기서 끊을게요
끝이 아니죠
인덕션까지 사용할 겁니다
아시다시피 인덕션은 전기 먹는 하마 수준인데요
전기차의 전기로 얼마나 오래 요리할 수 있는지 시험해볼 거예요
오늘은 고기를 삶지 않고 찔 거기 때문에 물은 조금만 채웠고요
수증기만으로도 존재감을 뿜어내는 강력한 향신료들을 넣을 거예요
마늘 한 주먹
통후추 30알
팔각 3개
월계수잎 3장을 넣었습니다
고기가 신선하다면 이거 다 필요 없어요
맹물도 돼요
이제 고기 뚜껑을 닫아 이대로 2시간 익히겠습니다
이야 윤기가 장난 아닌데요
예상치도 못했는데 팔각형이 예쁘네요
아주 먹음직스럽게 수육이 삶아졌습니다
고기 중심부도 70도 이상으로 완전히 다 익었습니다
엄청난 된장 수육이 만들어졌지만 솔직히 놀랍진 않죠
무수분 수육이라고 수증기에 찌는 수육은 꽤 대중적이거든요
그래서 지금부터 수추로 업그레이드 시킬 거예요
수추에 불을 붙여 하얗게 만든 뒤 호일 접시에 올려 담아놨어요
그 다음 이거는 훈연칩인데 물에 불려놨습니다
이것도 연기가 나긴 하는데
훈연칩이 있어야지 좀 맛있는 연기가 나요
연기가 뿜어져 나기도 하고
물에 불리지 않으면 연기가 잘 안 나더라고요
그냥 장작처럼 돼가지고
버리는 냄비라면 숯을 그냥 넣어도 되는데
저는 소중한 무쇠 냄비라서 호일 접시를 씁니다
숯 위에 훈연칩을 올리자마자
아주 향긋한 연기가 뿜어져 나오기 시작합니다
뚜껑을 아주 약간의 틈만 남긴 채로 덮으면 되는데요
원래 뚜껑을 닫으면 불이 꺼져야 정상이잖아요
근데 이 정도 틈을 열어 놓고
인덕션이나 레인지에서 계속 약불을 넣으면
숯이 계속 타고 연기도 계속 나옵니다
개인이 할 수 있는 수준에서
가장 집중적이고 확실한 훈연법이죠
이대로 30분은 기다려야 고기가 연기를 충분히 머금기 때문에
그동안 함께 먹을 사이드
비빔 칼국수를 만들 겁니다
그 유명한 물레동 01분식 스타일로 만들어 볼 거예요
백종원의 3대 천왕과 유퀴즈에 나왔었고
무엇보다 대한민국 면치기 열풍을 종식하게 만든
이정재님의 레전드짤이 여기 차렸분입니다
마트에서 산 생칼국수입니다
가루를 탈탈 털어서 약 5분간 삶을 거예요
채소는 빠르게 지나갑니다
오이 1개는 반으로 자른 뒤 어슷하게 썰어서 준비하고
상추는 대충 손으로 찢었습니다
양념장은 어제 집에서 미리 만들어 왔어요
고추장, 고춧가루, 설탕, 진간장, 식초, 참기름, 다진 마늘
매콤 새콤 달콤 양념장의 자세한 계량은 더보기에 써놓겠습니다
이제 잘 헹궈온 칼국수면에 잘 숙성된 양념장과
잘 익은 김치와 손질해둔 채소를 넣고 버무리면
엄청난 빛깔의 빛칼이 만들어집니다
마지막으로 한식 플레이팅에 국물, 깨를 듬뿍 뿌려 마무리하면
물레동 스타일 비빔 칼국수 완성입니다
이제 잘 훈연한 수육과 함께 얼른 먹어보겠습니다
냄비 뚜껑 훈제 수육
다음 기분
쨩
자 이렇게 냄비를 이용해서 냄비 뚜껑 수육 만들어 봤습니다
정말 아름다운 자태인데요
수육까지만 했을 때는 된장 수육 같았어요 솔직히
근데 훈연을 하고 나니까 완전 어나더 레벨의 요리가 됐습니다
훈연이 아주 듬뿍 먹여진 정가운데 조각을 먹어보겠습니다
대단히 맛있어 보입니다
훈연 색깔 보이시죠
훈제향이 씹자마자 바로 치고 들어옵니다
씹으면 씹을수록 나오는 된장향도 있어요
본격적으로 맛을 보기 전에 오늘의 광고주님 아이오닉5를 만나보시겠습니다
자 지금 캠핑장으로 향하고 있습니다
아이오닉5를 운전하고 있는데요
엑셀에 발을 갖다 대기만 해도
그냥 밀리미터 단위로 움직여도 쑥쑥 나가는 느낌이에요
가속감이 아주 좋습니다
제 실제 야차가 LPG 가스차거든요
그래서 조용함에 대한 기준이 되게 높은 편인데
아이오닉5는 정숙함의 차원이 다르네요
옆에 차들 소리만 들리고
이 차에 소리 거의 없는 수준으로
그 정도로 조용합니다
요즘 거리에 하늘색 번호판이 많이 있어서
전기차는 꽤 익숙해졌죠
근데 이렇게 전기를 뽑아 쓰는 기술
V2L은 낯선 분들이 꽤 많으실 거예요
여기가 오토 캠핑장이라 진짜 허허벌판이거든요
커피포트와 인덕션을 돌리고 있는 게
비현실적으로 느껴졌습니다
제 집에서 배터리 100%
600kWh로 출발해서
여기 캠핑장까지 약 55km 이동했더니
91%로 도착했고
그 후 거의 3시간 동안 가전을 팽팽 돌렸는데
인덕션을 거의 3시간을 돌렸는데
86%로 남았다는 것은 좀 충격입니다
이 정도면 밥솥, 선풍기
여러 가지 전기 가전을 돌려도
문제 없을 것 같아요
캠핑장에서 일반 가전 제품으로 요리를 하니까
정말 편하네요
아이오닉5만 있으면 어디서든 요리할 수 있겠습니다
이번엔 좀 바깥쪽 조각으로
훈제가 많이 뵌 조각
끝머리 부분 또 한 번 먹어볼게요
그냥 일반적인 수육이 아니에요
육향이 단단합니다
수육은 일단 그 맛있는 육즙과 육향을
물에 좀 뱉어내는 거잖아요
근데 이거는 쪘기 때문에
육향이 많이 담겨 있네요
거기에 이제 훈제까지 있으니까 더할 나위가 없습니다
이렇게 야매로 했다고 믿어지지 않을 정도로
훈제향이 아주 강하게 들어있는데
단순히 수출한 게 아니라
훈연 칩으로 한 게 티가 나요
이 육질이 여러분에게 느껴지면 좋겠는데
방금 갈비살 부위를 먹었습니다
뼈에 붙은 사이라서 육향도 좋고
거기 사이사이로 제가 되게 촘촘하게 된장을 발랐잖아요
된장의 맛이 싹 올라와서 맛이 장난이 아닙니다
약간 좀 얇게 도포라는 느낌이었는데
제 입맛에는 조금 더 발랐어도 좋았을 것 같아요
아까 육즙 짜는 거 보셨잖아요
이거보다 더 촉촉할 수 있었는데
유튜브 찍기 짜고 짜버렸어
원래도 비계가 맛있잖아요
살이 쪄서 그렇지 겁나 맛있는데
수육의 문제가 마이야르가 없는 건데
이게 구워져 있어서
그것까지 좀 보완을 하는 효과가 있네요
유튜버 행동 들어가겠습니다
여러분은 또 들고 뜨는 거 좋아하시니까
갈비살 쫙 이제 갈비뼈가 있던 자리에
가장 맛있는 부위로 한입 크게 한 번 뜯어 볼게요
이건 진짜 맛있겠다
방금 한 입은 올해의 한입 후보입니다
촉각 후각 미각 공감각으로 몰아치네요 몰아쳐
뽀드득 뽀드득 들어가요 이렇게
자 이제 비빔면 갑니다
솔직히 말해서 좀 불었을 거예요
아
많이 불었을 거예요
거의 죽기 일보 지점인데
빨리 먹어야 될 거 같아요
근데 색깔은 진짜 개 레전드에요 진짜
이게 비빔면이지
와 이거 찢었다
이 칼국수는 채식천재인 제 와이프가 레시피를 만들어 줬거든요
뭐 블로그 한 서너 개 보고 합했다고 제가 들었는데
이거 미쳤는데요 여러분 이거 무조건 따라 하세요
여기 그대로 올려서 비카레 수육 미쳤어요
미쳤어요
미쳤다
레전드입니다
이정재 님도 이거 먹어서 면치기 했을 수도 있어요
그건 오버인가
김치를 넣는 게 미쳤네
김치에 따라서 편차가 있을 수 있는데
이거 레시피 장난 아닌데
보셔서 알겠지만 양은 냄비 해도 되고
아끼시는 냄비면 저처럼 호일 그릇만 깔고 하시면 되는 거고
뚜껑만 있는 아무 냄비나 해도 돼요 버리는 냄비 다 괜찮거든요
수육을 먹는 완벽한 방법 중 하나니까
캠핑 좋아하시는 분들 마당이 있거나 옥상이 있으신 분들 꼭 한번 해보세요
고기가 식기 전에 얼른 와이프와 스태프들과 둘러 앉았습니다
모두들 수육의 퀄러티와 비칼과의 조화에 깜짝 놀랐어요
역시 야외 음식의 묘미는 함께하는 재미인 것 같습니다
오늘 요리는 여러 가지 장점이 있죠
진한 훈연향이 있고 수치의 열 때문에 마이야르까지 있어요
수육처럼 덩어리 고기인데
수육처럼 덩어리 고기인데 마이야르까지 있어요
수중기로 쪘기 때문에 육향이 물로 덜 빠지게 되죠
근데 단점으로 시간이 더 걸린다고 느끼실 수 있어요
분명 2시간 플러스 30분은 적진 않죠
하지만 그 사이 아무것도 안 해서 생각외로 되게 괜찮았습니다
숯불구이를 하면 내내 불앞을 지키며 뒤집어야 하잖아요
이 요리는 딱 뚜껑 닫아놓으면 할 일이 없어요
특별한 고가의 장비가 필요한 것도 아니라서
야외에서 고기 먹는 모든 시청자분들에게 자신있게 추천드리겠습니다
사랑하는 120만의 구독자 여러분 항상 감사합니다
땡큐!